here's the big breaking news it just
just came down um it's been updated in
the past 15 or so minutes
but uh you know earlier i did a segment
on the the feud that was going on so i
definitely want to talk about this
canvassers meeting because i'm
i'm thinking i don't know man these
republicans that were on the
the board of canvassers to certify the
vote for biden this guy was trying
in every way possible to make sure he
would give biden the win
even though there were serious
challenges we talked about pennsylvania
or which state michigan michigan okay
okay
uh what county uh wayne county wayne
county yeah yeah but let's uh we'll
let's let's just uh breaking news
breaking news oh sure they say the board
of state canvassers certified michigan's
november general election results monday
the board made up of two republicans and
two democrats met november 23rd
to make the vote count official after 83
michigan counties certified their
election results which includes joe
biden's 2.8
statewide victory over trump they say
aaron van
langeveld a republican canvasser and an
attorney for the house republican caucus
said the board doesn't have many options
outside of performing its duty to
certify the election
quote this board must respect authority
entrusted to it and follow the law as it
is written
we must not attempt to exercise power we
do not have van langeveld said
we have a clear legal duty to certify
the results of this election we cannot
and should not go beyond that
and i'm going to stop right there and
say i completely agree with this
republican except
they're not doing their duty at all so
one of the arguments that was brought
forward was certify means to
determine the veracity to to assert that
it's true and correct
and they literally don't do that they're
just like hear the results have a nice
day rubber stamp move on well i thought
that was an interesting
way to word it too i've been following
that in wayne county where they're
basically saying
it's their job to certify the election
but like as you said
not really yeah that but that's part of
what you do
but you didn't do the other part of the
job so i mean
to come in now and say well i'm just
doing my job this is for america
um he's scared of the mob yes right what
we saw with doxing and and um
family threats and things like that yeah
he's terrified yeah
so uh for those that aren't familiar
wayne county which has detroit
previously was deadlocked 2-2
uh the left and democrats started naming
where these these these
republicans kids were going to school
they were getting legit threats and then
they
they issued an affidavit saying we were
pressured into this we were tricked into
it
they were promised an audit and that was
that was reported there was going to be
an audit and they're saying nope we're
not going to do it too bad you lose
so now it's coming to this guy and but
here's the thing the other republican
there are two republicans he abstained
what he didn't even vote no what so look
man i tell you
you got a lot of people who think it's
the end of the world they're saying you
know if if trump does lose this and
biden gets in it's going to be great
reset it's going to be
you know all of the worst possible
things massive lockdown and the
lockdown's getting crazy
and uh if you don't got any republicans
who are willing to stand up and say no
well then dude i probably already lost
yeah and the political space i mean not
like the literal war or anything
yeah there are figures there are a few
states where republicans
stood tall and you know i think
if you're worried about lockdowns i mean
trump's the president write down right
now look what's happening in california
new york pennsylvania trying to get
people to you know wear masks in their
own home
yeah it's it's what do you i mean
lockdowns like i mean they're here
the lockdowns are here right now and
unless you have a state with um
really it seems like a republican
dominant supreme court
you're living under these rules you see
that minnesota tried to
have a thousand dollar fine for
socializing with somebody outside of
your house um and then a 25 000
fine if you publicly said you weren't
going to obey these rules yeah that was
uh came out of the governor
i'm sure it didn't pass but this was
what he proposed that's like one state
away from me
and it's i mean what do you mean joe
biden is not president right now
yeah where are you at do you want to
wisconsin yeah wisconsin
and then uh this is crazy newark new
jersey they're saying you can't leave
your home at all
but apparently now there's people saying
like try me and so we don't know if
they're gonna enforce it but they tried
saying you don't leave your house
but let's let's let's take a look at
this um real quick
they say charlie spies who represents
senate candidate john james said the
meeting should be adjourned until wayne
county's results are audited
our position isn't that that this
election shouldn't be certified
but the board of state canvassers should
only do do that when it's confident that
results it is certifying are correct
literally what certifying means i'll
tell you it was crazy about this board
meeting earlier
yeah this one guy aaron van uh you know
langeveld whatever his name is
this dude's clearly terrified of the mob
and um
look well i'll put it away it's my
opinion but he was doing
everything in his power to justify why
he would not try and get this looked
into
so you had one guy it was this guy
charlie's charlie spies who represents
john james senate candidate
and he said according to you know
section 116 it says you have the
authority to
certify the results you know and that is
defined legally as
determining whether it's true which
means your job is to determine whether
this is true and you have that authority
to do so
this guy aaron starts saying oh i don't
see anything within the
statutes that grants me that power and
then he says it even says you have the
right to adjourn
for any necessary purpose and then this
republican guy goes
well i mean i can't just make something
up and they're like you're not you
if you want to certify the results are
true then it means there needs to be an
audit
that means you adjourn until you have
the ability to certify the results are
true
so basically what happened in wayne
county was that
there's a signature books i guess is my
understanding
and there were more people who have
signed in than there were people who or
there was a different amount of people
who signed and then voted
creating a massive discrepancy in like
70
of of the you know the voting precincts
or whatever and they couldn't figure out
really how to
rectify that either right i think that's
where they stuck they were basically
like
we know this is wrong but we have no way
to it's kind of like with the mailing
ballots once they throw out the envelope
they can't right signature verification
dude how crazy
is it that what we have learned i'm i'll
tell you this
if all that ends up coming out of
trump's legal battles for the presidency
is that
we have these lawsuits and the results
then i'm eternally grateful i'm trying
to because here's what we learned
we learned that if you have uh an
unbalanced
you know uh ballot book or whatever
where you have more voters than votes
and
and less voters than votes doesn't
matter no one seems to care hey no
that's fine we'll rub or stamp that and
send it on through
and in pennsylvania what's really crazy
sir thurket
uh third circuit third circuit
court of appeals uh just dismissed
trump's appeal
saying that they have no standing and
this was the suit
claiming that there were no observers
for 682 thousand
votes so you know that means it means
that you can be running election
and you can straight up just tell a
massive urban voting
you know accounting center okay kick all
the republicans out break them all out
and now we're going to say everything is
for our candidate and they can't do
anything about it
because the courts have already ruled we
don't have to wasn't that guy never
trump or two
uh the guy in pennsylvania am i thinking
of the right guy he
he the guy who ruled against it i feel
like something came out where he was a
never trumper
interesting oh yeah yeah there's
something the first guy
i think it was the first uh the state
level i guess yeah yeah yeah
now trump's campaign has said this is a
good thing because it means they're
getting closer to scotus
as if like why would why would it matter
if it's scotus or a federal judge
if you lose you lose and you you appeal
and then i mean unless they think
they've got some political clout among
specific judges well you don't have amy
coney barrett
right now either right she's recused
herself from has she i thought she
recused herself from any
is that not true i felt like she said
she had recused herself from
that would yeah i hadn't heard about
that any type of election
i know they were asking her to and i
think she kept saying i can't give you
an opinion on okay
okay but i don't know that district yes
she was just put in charge of what she
was here he could have checked out back
checked it let me know
lydia again but uh they just did the new
uh scotus appointments
where they assigned the judges to
different circuits yeah so also maybe
that yeah that doesn't make sense then
if she's gonna proceed over
you know wisconsin no no i mean it
doesn't mean she's gonna preside over an
election case
but okay okay yeah so the the fact that
the federal judge
kicked back uh and dismissed trump's
lawsuit
within like i think it was like two and
a half hours or something that actually
could be good because the one thing i
think that might matter if it goes to
the supreme court is that
they might have some it might have a
bigger impact outside of just that
specific circuit so if they rule the
federal
you know the supreme court level mail-in
votes for this reason are no good
then the whole election is just upended
well well let's play a game right let's
say
that that's true what's what happens
there do you just say yeah we're just
not going to count
these 700 000 votes are they recast
i mean let's say hypothetically you know
this has been my struggle is where
there's smoke as you put it
you know it's like okay well then what
you know like okay you just throw out
700 000 votes
i don't i can't see that happening
there's there's no circumstance where i
think any rational person has faith in
our elections anymore
a lot of people are black-pilled which
sucks i i'm really s i see it in my
comment sections i see it in your live
chat
i see a lot of faith loss in the
election system and
and i agree that trump is doing a good
thing
by at least fighting this and exposing
some things because hopefully
these things can be corrected in
particular uh let's worry about like
fewer mailing ballots where people can
go to somebody's house and just say like
here i filled it up for you just sign
you know like that kind of stuff
i've i only have faith in elections
because trump won the won the first
place
like when when hillary was running i was
like what's the point right and then
when she didn't win i was like whoa
he must have won by of seven million
votes you know that's how i
mean i felt he must have won by a
landslide if he had managed
because i figured they would have tried
every little thing you know yeah
trump ended up winning and then i
thought wow i guess people can really
win well okay so then i voted this time
around and then you know now now
you know biden's projected to win and
based on
what we've learned throughout these
lawsuits yeah i got very little faith in
the election system at all
like the fact that we've got all these
sworn affidavits of impropriety in
georgia
you've got a sworn statement from i
think there's like i read like five
different affidavits
where they were saying things like i
watched them pull up votes that were
perfectly you know
not not folded no creases and it looked
like it was machine printed
what about all the post office ones did
all those affidavits go away where
people are saying
i swear you know people were swearing
the fact that they were back dating
voters i don't care
yeah that just disappeared we're
supposed to just sit here and be like
well we have a usps whistleblower who
said they were
more than one i think it was more than
one we've got numerous affidavits out of
georgia
we've got numerous mathematical
anomalies that have been tracked even by
those like a yale professor i guess who
was like wow that doesn't make sense
and then we've got uh the voter
integrity fund which has found
thousands of voters in georgia who used
fake addresses
apparently adding apartment numbers to
commercial
addresses and mailboxes and we're
supposed to ignore everything and carry
on like everything's okay and just
assume hey you know what this is
legitimate and
come on come on man come on come on
so if if this is how it really ends then
why would i bother participating in an
election ever again
i hope people don't don't i i understand
that line of thinking but what i think
is
that people who feel that way should be
really concerned about getting involved
in election reform
specifically mail-in ballots look if
you're an active duty military person
and you're overseas
100 understand why that exists but the
idea that
the fact that you cannot like there were
literally people
that were going door to door and helping
people fill out balance
i talked to you before the show i said
people showed up at my home
looking for my wife to say like has she
voted
what were they there to what were they
doing there and and i've said before
yeah they weren't from they weren't from
around there
is what i'll say they weren't from my
city they clearly weren't there stumping
for trump
and i do think trump made a tactical
error spending too much time
trying to discredit mail-in ballots
bouts and not
uh trying to slow them stop them or
encourage his republican base to still
use them because i feel like there are
people
who didn't go on election day and then
they're like well trump says mail and
ballots are no good so i'm just not even
going to do that you know i feel like
that was a that was a trump error that
was definitely tactical error
you know that we had like half a million
rejected ballots in the democratic
primary
mail-in belts well yeah did you see how
many they rejected the presidential
election yeah where are six
where are they yeah it's unprecedented
yeah so we're supposed to sit here
watching the news i'm i'm just citing
news the these stories about uh
potential fraud and irregularity
are coming from like regular old news
outlets
local news too local news yeah i guess i
guess it's
what they expect of us every single one
of us just ignores it because
every single you know here's the way i
describe it to people imagine you're
walking past the building
you hear the smoke alarm going off and
you're like wow smoke alarm usually
means fire huh
so you call 9-1-1 and you say hey a
smoke alarm going off and the operator
goes
did you see any fire there's no
widespread fires currently on record
yeah right right we have no reports of
widespread fire anywhere no but the
alarm is going off sir
unless you have evidence of widespread
fire in the building
do you want me to go inside and check
i'll tell you what happens when the
smoke alarm goes off the fire department
shows up they come outside they go false
alarm and you go thank you and then you
feel better
you feel safer so that's that's that's
the bare minimum
this is the great thing i'm saying if
democrats are so confident it's over and
they've won
then why don't they just say okay baby
here's your bottle we're going to do
your little audit for you and waste time
and energy and then we're going to hold
it over you
well why we're blocking it yeah why
wouldn't they want to
double own trump like this would be the
double
drum phone and honestly like for all the
money
that our government wastes uh you know
foreign wars and all this kind of stuff
like i don't know maybe spend it on
making sure our elections good and not
have just
one dude be like this is the safest
election in american history
but you know before any audits have been
done before any any evidence had been
out
people are just like oh well i mean we
saw how the fbi
current you know had their political
leanings we had comey
um yeah we know that there's a rot from
inside so
i think people like myself are like oh
well the guy from the fbi says
okay well all right you know like we
know that they're partisan
and you know go on you know it's a
really good example of something i talk
about all the time
i talk about how you'll get some kind of
evidence of impropriety
or you know criminal activity and then
all of a sudden you'll get some fringe
conspiracy theory
everyone adopts that theory and then all
of a sudden you can't talk about the
actual problem anymore
so for example i reference like
pizzagate for instance
there are a lot of questionable emails
it seems like they're talking in code
saying weird things yeah probably just
code for drugs or something
some kind of improper action right right
then all of a sudden you get people
talking about pizza places and
and you know satan and the guy shows up
and goes crazy with the rifle and shoots
the floor and all of a sudden it's shut
up
ignore this yeah and so we have all of
this evidence of impropriety
and then i'll tell you and i know the
trump supporters get mad
when sydney powell went on tv and she
went on newsmax and said
that governor kemp was taking money from
the communists and working against trump
or whatever i was like
right away she derailed yeah the
legitimate conversation
and don't take my word for it the trump
campaign issued a statement
yeah they disavowed her almost
immediately that's what that's what
they'll that's what the left is saying
the right is saying they're they're just
positioning her so that she's you know
acting now independent or whatever and
i'm like dude listen it read like a
disavow to me
right you know exactly yeah the fact
that they had to issue a statement
saying she's doing things on her own
come on the trump campaign knows their
legal path to victory
and they know what she was saying wasn't
including it and the thing she was
bringing up about dominion and
smartmatic and all the stuff
is just too out there you can't prove it
in a court
so saying all these things over and over
again that's that's what i talk about
all the time
it's a it's it's it's man it's so easy
to to derail when someone's actually on
your
on your tail with what you're doing and
they're like oh
they figured it out they've they've
noticed all of these you know affidavits
swearing fraud quick
throw him something ridiculous about
venezuela poison the well yeah exactly
well and and like to be honest what's
infuriating for me
is for the last four years we were
supposed to believe that russia flipped
the entire 2016 election
you had these clips of that shill john
oliver
my opinion not tim's uh like a year ago
he's like
voting machines we shouldn't be using
voting machines they're they're prone to
errors
and then like one year later voting
machines are the most secure thing ever
how can you see it you got to see his
tweet it was a really clever play on
words
he did a 20-minute segment where he's
like this woman went in current year and
flipped the election in two minutes yeah
come on people and i'm like
so he has a lady do a demonstration
where she walks the machine she takes a
ballpoint pen
pops it open and she pulls out the drive
and swaps it or whatever and took her
less than two minutes
and then they issued a statement on
twitter where they're like
notice the you may have noticed
conservative media is pushing this
narrative
yeah well the truth is the biggest
problem as we said is blah blah blah and
i'm like
wait the biggest problem i don't care
about the biggest problem i care about
problems
well that's the poisoning the wealth
thing right it's almost like they gave
them something totally absurd that some
regular old horse mom
you know had a memory card the right
kind of memory card by the way it's not
just any memory card you'd have to know
oh it's a mini xd or it's whatever then
you'd have to have votes on it
unless i guess you could steal it from
like a democratic stronghold
but even set like it's just so absurd
this is this is the game they play
he does a 20-minute segment where he
says here's a list of problems
a b c d e but the biggest problem is
clearly a
then when you bring up whoa we found
evidence of b he goes
we said a was the biggest problem right
right yes but you also said
b was a problem too so that's how
they're trying to fake backtrack it's a
framing device
where stupid people are going to be like
oh he's saying it's not real
well it's also the same thing where they
try to gas by people and say
well nobody dead voted there were no
dead voters but yeah yeah
absolutely there were yes there are in
most elections but they'll gaslight and
say
well it wasn't enough to change election
okay well ten thousand here
you got four five thousand votes georgia
all this stuff adds up my my position is
i i don't care if it flipped the
election or not
why are there dead voters right right
fix the problem there was a fact check i
saw this is funny
they were like no you know what what's
uh flekas
they're like uh fleka's put out this
tweet saying they found 10
000 dead voters you know having voted or
whatever so we did a random sampling of
50 people and found
two of them were still alive one person
was wrongly labeled it was actually
their son of the same name and yes in
fact one person was dead but this proves
and i'm like
wait wait you found a dead person who
voted one in 50.
i know something like that i'm like
shouldn't we like
check that because that's weird how did
that happen well maybe if you didn't
have mail-in ballot bouts
you know what i mean and you could go
there was this article by
vice today or the other day would you
see where they put out like maybe we
should make
voting mandatory yeah yeah that was
buzzfeed or buzzfeed yeah yeah yeah
you know that in australia it is
mandatory though and they only get 90 to
95
turnout yeah and there were many
jurisdictions across the us with more
than a hundred percent turn out
interesting and they offered up all
different explanations tim
spare me your alt-right conspiracy
theories i read all the articles about
you before i came on the show
i was i've i've got my d ralph
radicalization suit on underneath this
hoodie
just come on it never happened it
couldn't possibly happen
why why won't you guys just accept that
joe biden is your
supreme chancellor already i mean i mean
president president
president yeah oops wait did i say it
too soon yeah yeah
i think it was supreme leader i'm not
sure yeah yeah right i'm not even
convinced
like so look i actually don't think
there's uh there needs to be any kind of
grand conspiracy either there's a lot of
people seem to think there is like rudy
giuliani says
it appears to be coming from a
centralized place and i'm like the same
place he bought it here his hair died
probably yeah problematic but
look at antifa doesn't need a leader to
organize in different cities
they they do have leaders but here's how
it operates there's no like national
antifa guy who's like everybody go to
this place
right there are active there's like
passive and active antifa
there are antifa people who are very
very active who are vetting people and
they're the ones running the websites
and they'll be like hey we're gonna go
protest in berkeley send the word out to
the other groups
and then they all show up so when it
comes to an election when you see weird
anomalies in weird numbers it could be
because
where are the where are the rejected
mail in ballots rejection rates are
supposed to be like one or two percent
they're nowhere to be we're not
rejecting ballots so probably what's
happening is you get one or two people
who are like this is fine to me
and we one of the rulings in
pennsylvania was that even though people
failed to fill out their address and
date the actual uh
the envelopes the judge said no that's
fine that's acceptable
it's like well what would it be tim how
do you how do you know it came from the
person
well because the form itself says it but
but who filled out the envelope and sent
it in well we talked about before going
on air that i received and my wife
received mail in ballots
we never requested them yeah it takes at
least in my state just a name
and a birth date which is publicly
available there are absolutely
political groups that are mailing these
things and then you follow that up with
people showing up at your house being
like hey have you have you felt like a
mail about well let me help you because
there have been several videos of people
like
on the porch with some poor old granny
who's like you know baking
some sort of friendship bread or
something and then they're like oh well
no okay so you want to vote for biden
right
and then oh okay and then like all this
ballot harvesting in minnesota all
that's all just
alt-right consumption gone never
happened yeah it never happened even
though there was video evidence of a
dude doing it
right um this again goes back to we
strongly
need to reconsider mail in balloting
it's just too insecure
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all next time
you